if you lost track of lou diamond
phillips after longmire ended we've
tallied up some of the best ways to
catch up with him here's what phillips
has been up to since the acclaimed
wyoming set crime drama aired its final
episode in 2017.
even when lou diamond phillips didn't
have a regular tv series he was still a
familiar face on tv turning up regularly
in prominent guest star spots in just
about every genre this hasn't changed
since longmire wrapped phillips has
turned up on crime procedurals like
criminal minds and ncis new orleans as
well as landed a juicy recurring role on
blue bloods and notably it's only a
recurring role because of phillips he
was too good for the show to let him go
after only one episode as blue blood
star donnie wahlberg explained in an
interview with pop culture phillips's
character louis delgado was originally
slated to die in his first episode but
wahlberg loved working with phillips too
much for that to happen he told pop
culture it's just rare you get to work
with somebody you click with so well and
they're amazing at what they do i feel
like he makes me a better actor and he
makes our show a better show phillips's
part on blue bloods was accordingly
expanded and his character wound up
having a rich complex connection with
wahlberg's danny reagan
lou diamond phillips has a distinctive
voice and lightly he's been putting it
to good use since the longmire finale in
2017 phillips has more than doubled the
amount of voice acting on his resume on
disney's the lion guard a lion king
spin-off series he provided the voice
for surak he also had a recurring role
on the children's show elena of avalor
and did a guest spot on family guy this
is an intriguing new direction for
phillips and it's one that makes a lot
of sense he's always worked hard to make
sure his career was as multi-faceted as
possible in an interview with upi he
said i literally trace this versatility
back to my theater days which started in
high school and then with my degree from
the university of texas in arlington i
did everything notably voice acting is
also an easy way for him to make
appearances on children's shows like
elena of avalor he told yahoo finance
that as a father he really appreciates
the effort to provide more diverse
children's programming
after longmire if you wanted your
regular lou diamond phillips fix your
best bet was the 2019 crime show
prodigal son where he played nypd
lieutenant gil arroyo warm and
level-headed arroyo is kind of a natural
successor to henry standing bear
phillips told upi the integrity and the
moral compass of gil arroyo is very much
like that of henry but one is a very
rural guy a native american and the
other is an urban filipino so it's nice
to have that latitude the role is
similar enough that longmire fans should
check the show out but still different
enough to be a change of pace for
phillips he likes to keep things fresh
prodigal son is a dark crime drama about
an investigator whose father was a
serial killer the cases of the week can
delve into some extreme territory but
cast chemistry and sympathetic
characters keep it grounded while the
show was unfortunately canceled after
its second season two seasons of gil
arroyo are definitely better than none
while lou diamond phillips actually did
a little directing before longmire the
series opened the door for him to do
even more when he directed season six's
fever he clearly caught the directing
bug it's not that unusual for actors to
get the chance to direct an episode on
their own shows but phillips really took
the ball and ran with it he didn't just
take the reins on longmire and prodigal
son where he was a serious regular he
also directed an episode of agents of
shield as well as an episode of fear the
walking dead
i feel very honored that they've given
me and trusted me an opportunity to you
know to tell this story it's probably
easier he admitted in an interview with
nerds and beyond to keep his directing
and acting separate phillips told the
outlet i've often gotten so caught up in
watching my other actors during a scene
that i forget my own lines that's why we
have multiple takes we can also look
forward to seeing more of this side of
phillips's career the actor went on to
add i absolutely love directing and
consider it to be simply yet another
branch of my creative tree i truly enjoy
working with the other artists
cinematographers production designers
stunt coordinators every crew member
really to take great ideas and actualize
them
longmire fans who miss lou diamond
phillips can also look for him in a
surprising place the bookstore in
october 2020 he published the young
adult science fiction novel the
tinderbox soldier of indira phillips
told nerds and beyond that the story
stemmed from the manga style concept art
his wife had done for a prospective
graphic novel philip started the project
off as a screenplay and reverse
engineered the story into a novel a
project that took 10 years he told upi
that 2020 lockdowns gave him the time he
needed to buckle down and finish and the
results are impressive the nerd daily
reviewed the book saying phillips has
skillfully woven together a fantastical
story with realistic touchstones the
plot is driving the characters are
memorable and the writing is satisfying
enhanced by the striking drawings
phillips has built a world here which
readers will undoubtedly wish to visit
again they might be in luck phillips
confirmed with upi that a second book is
already in the works with some novel
writing experience now under his belt
we're betting readers won't have to wait
10 years for this next one check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]